very simply we have to make happiness
the North Star
we have to because the framework of all
of us over the last hundred years is
success and even worse things you hadn't
even debated
like being unhappy is a bad idea and if
that unhappiness is predicated on
because it's the business that's paying
your bills you need to figure out how to
change your bills sell your [ __ ] home
like downsize your car like take one
less vacation stop keeping up with the
[ __ ] Joneses
[Music]
[Music]
Twitter what up hang with Nora from
empathy whines here in Ohio
we're chatting and we decided that some
of you were just still not past the
finish line and so Nora is ready to
literally call you and explain to you
why it's time to subscribe to Anthony
once that was really good I mean I
thrive off of bad comments like you just
use any negativity to just keep fighting
through yeah actually it's it's less of
like that it's just more of empathy like
that person doesn't have enough context
to have a statement that matters enough
both pro and con it's the same reason
that I don't get too high it's the same
reason that I'm not in some private room
right now not talking to anybody like
the accolades feel the same way as the
hate so it just keeps it super balanced
got it and 20 people love the accolades
but don't want to deal with the hate
which makes them and then they keep
buying into the accolades and they think
there's somebody which that means the
hate drives them down even more the more
you are driven down by hate is the more
that you read the press clippings of the
good [ __ ] that you've been told I just
keep it right down the [ __ ] middle
this is great stuff huh d-roc I'm like
so pumped you rock beings just like
watching him film something just now on
the phone and then just watching him
editing the 2009 video like I'm
literally at my happiest I've been in a
long time I think what do you mean
access story that things like that right
there on your story yeah do it okay or
do you want me to know my account to
your phone and let's go you should have
every one of my social accounts like
snap to for that matter let's go so when
I was in Hong Kong it really really
struck me this woman came up to me and
said I appreciate everything done you
changed my life I was too seriously
depressed but I have to tell you I
watched one garyvee video
save my life and I said oh what did what
which one was it taste she said and you
really resonated me because it's what
you say and how you say it it was simply
if you're depressed no one [ __ ] cares
do something about it right it's you but
it's the hardest message you know the
reason 25 percent of people don't like
me on first impact or have to go through
how many people here when they first
consume he didn't like me raise it high
race and I it's fine I just want to give
the context one more time I just want to
say it yeah like it makes sense because
when you're willing to go somewhere at
your own expense in the short term but
you know it's right we all have that I
have my same versions we all have a
button we all and and so it makes sense
to me and I don't like it like I can be
more popular have more fun but but it it
makes sense to me because there's a lot
of truth at the IPPS I mean especially
in the climate we live in America today
it's not fun to say things like nobody
cares because we're trying to figure out
how to collectively care but the reality
is
if you believe that somebody else is in
charge you're already in trouble you're
gonna be in a bad place doesn't mean
that there isn't racism doesn't mean
that you if you have a [ __ ] up mom
you're gonna have some stuff doesn't
mean that there isn't gender issue it
doesn't mean there isn't problems but if
that's your framework you know look I
you know I think people heard me say
this I think the person that's the most
[ __ ] on earth is a trust-fund baby
number one number one person I'm
grateful that I didn't pop out of the
womb as was somebody who came into five
hundred million dollars in a trust fund
from parents that had made it because
you've lost to society before you've
started but the one that I think we're
gonna involve into is mental mental
privilege if you're born with the mental
capacity to be happy or have the right
perspective on life or understand half
glass full like that's why people that
look like they shouldn't win win all the
time they got they were they their
privilege was mentality and perspective
and so I'm spending a lot of time
thinking about that
but you can't see that we can all look
at each other and see what everybody
looks like you're I have no idea if
you're grounded as [ __ ] like I am behind
your facade that's the ultimate [ __ ]
privilege
and then sit down hello hello
for me and for the audience I know for a
lot of people out here they have amazing
stories to share but sometimes it's
really hard to share their most
vulnerable things in life and I was just
wondering if you can give me a tip to
overcome that fear the acknowledgement
of it I think the thing that I've come
to realize in the last four to five
years has become a bigger theme is
everybody's biggest beautiful secret
right this second is the jail of their
happiness a hundred percent you know but
a lot of people don't even realize
that's happening they think that's
protecting them and so this becomes a
monster game of judgment a monster game
of judgment and I don't have a tip I
what I'm trying to do is bring awareness
to it right like if you study how we've
eliminated stigmas in our society it's
by bringing awareness to it and that's
what I think a lot about what I hear
that question you know I just when I'm
with the closest people or if it's
one-on-one
I just always ask them like what I'm
usually it's only four to five people
that they're worried about like they
don't love the judgement of Sally pants
89 they really don't like the judgement
of friends and acquaintances but the
reality is the reason they're not
sharing their deepest [ __ ] is it usually
involves a four or five persons in their
life yeah I think for me the hardest
part is you know I have a massive scar
and a lot of people sometimes worry what
they think and me being very fit when I
was just you know that's a day yeah it's
very hard to share some of that you know
share my actual particle I you know what
do you think about this do you remember
like in high school when you had a zit
like you thought about that [ __ ] heavy
the reality is nobody gave a [ __ ]
because they had their own [ __ ] zip
and that's how I think about all this
[ __ ] like I think people are gonna be
people would be flabbergasted by how
nobody really gives a [ __ ] what makes it
super easy for me with all the you know
attention I have
is ultimately I know you don't give a
[ __ ] you can't it's not your fault you
have to worry about yourself we watched
some of the most iconic people look at
the society we live in now iconic people
that have brought so much value in
whatever they do pass away they trend on
Twitter for four hours they get a little
love maybe on Instagram posts and the
next day everybody moves on with their
life that's liberating nobody gives a
[ __ ] about the scar on your stomach bro
because we have our own scars in
different ways that's my answer to why
it's so easy you're welcome
[Applause]
thanks for standing up thanks brother I
did it more for the for everybody else
man you know I'm starting to share it
thank you brother listen I will do drama
you guys seem gas station there I
believe that I believe it makes sense I
probably don't have the same amount of
healthy feared respected everyone else
here does understood but so do every
sense like a lot of life plot twists
with my graduating recently do you like
it I do I do I like great oh I mean if
you're lucky enough like there is no
greatest gift greater gift and liking
and being good like liking something and
being good at it is like like that's the
that's how I have my life like that's a
great like literally like that's the
Holy Grail yeah I think the thing that
you need to do as this young of an age
is not overthinking go all-in and then
if you wake up in 36 months and say I
don't like it like pulling sales like if
you intuitively are in a place with that
answer of like I like it and I'm good at
it you should go all-in
you mean selling wise a hundred percent
hey listen to me
take less money selling something you
believe in cuz you're so [ __ ] young
and time is your friend kids don't feel
that way because they want to prove it I
get it
but it's but it's the truth it's it's
God here's why that will always be there
for you you can do that in four years
and still be young as [ __ ] right now go
sell [ __ ] the thing that you [ __ ]
are most on fire about because then
you're into it you're selling into
selling and [ __ ] like it now you can
really get ridiculous results please sir
because I know I have a story to tell I
just wanted to know how with somebody
like myself get to that business
motivations here's what I would say
don't go on the stage until you're ready
for everything and the only way you're
fully ready for anything everything is
when you share everything on your terms
my my advice is that one or two things
that aren't out there you get ahead of
them play a Tribune your old video a
mini doc own it so that's because once
you get out there you'll do well
you [ __ ] odd here it's a very
intriguing story for a lot of people in
culture what I don't want is for as
that's building and it's working and it
becomes a real thing for you that there
is one or two things that you haven't
gotten to and then your oh you always
know that that's out you know and I hear
you secretly and know it will come up or
because you don't want it to come up you
suppress your upside if you've gotten to
a place where you're putting in the
right context that's a universal story
for everybody around everything the
death of a parent the a business failing
public like it's your stories
universally important and if you're one
that's on the other side of it and it's
the contagion control of it you have a
lot of value to bring and then the fact
that it's so star power E versus like
just a gal whose business went out of
business when it looked like she was
building a big business that's just not
gonna capture hundreds of thousands of
people you have the luxury of it will
capture millions of people so I would
say get your [ __ ] right up here and then
the second you feel like you're ready
like you'll I did I basically made
pretend what question
can be asked that would most make me
feel awkward on stage and once that
answer was nothing I [ __ ] went crazy
[Laughter]
feel free to reach out
[Music]
you find it possible to be able to have
multiple streams or do you have to find
a niche in a sector I think I think
multiple works especially if it's true
to that purse everything I've been
selling cuz it's true to me but
everything I tell he's like you've got
to find your mark you got to go and
that's like it's not me I love
everything I could literally say I love
every knee - and you're [ __ ] killing
her
you inspire so I appreciate that but
that's it I just wanted to know if that
was ever if you just want to possum in
this market different people do
different things and different things
work for different people like it's
people too often give advice that is too
literal to them without taking it to the
higher level like for me you know it's
like the content question it's about
self awareness video work for me because
I end up being good at it I didn't know
that until I started doing it
the first need is to spend no time
worrying about them and quadrupling down
on your customer and then getting in
people with them so they don't need and
then refocusing on getting more that is
not that's not something you can control
yeah totally the answer I'd six liquor
stores open up around me as we were
exploding I put zero dates on the number
one wheel when somebody surrounds you is
to pay attention zero today just the
customer
[Music]
thank you
that's that's the framework of my life I
have like 13 17 29 principles you know
what's amazing tick-tock and LinkedIn
and whatsapp are the biggest thing I
talk about my team today
not a peep about that [ __ ] six months
ago
[Music]
that's what's so great about like what I
think I've got I've got a foundational
capability and concept that is
completely predicated on a moving target
right I'm I want to be the best of the
world at observing where attention is
and are executing on it
good news Gary attention we'll move
until the day you die thinking about
saying thinking about saying [ __ ] less
and changing it to duck
since my [ __ ] keyboard always
autocorrects it is that the right way
that's 100 gen that's right [ __ ] ya
Jason
let's go Lenny facts Geoff you filming
this beautiful I'm so [ __ ] tired of
people being confused that it's me
actually engaging with you that I've now
converted to voice on the text messaging
platform no confusion this isn't Jason
typing this is an Andy or d-roc typing
it's me [ __ ]
it's me yo I want to get on stage can
you wrap this up hi to people on I'm a
library to people after like five
minutes it was like such a good feeling
I was like this is the [ __ ] dirt this
is the dirt this is what I [ __ ] you
couldn't you should have seen my face I
was like this right yo d-roc put in the
thread I want to find a filter that
makes me look like a baby and I'm gonna
post it I want an image is that
snapchats got a baby one yeah
where is it like yeah it guys I need it
right away like get in the thread like I
need a baby ASAP I got it
I need that cliff
the ethics of my that's your life right
alive
where's the car brother car
[Music]